here's the first story that we got
timgas.com
Trump's YouTube has been restored post's
first video in two years this channel
will continue to be subject to our
policies just like any other channel
ladies and gentlemen let me just scroll
right down here is the video from Donald
J Trump sorry to keep you waiting
complicated business complicated
that was it sorry to keep you awaiting
complicated business complicated four
seconds four seconds of Donald Trump
posted it's got a hundred and fifteen
thousand views and then the other big
news that Trump is back on Facebook he
posts for the first time on Facebook
since January 6 2021 and I think he just
posted big capital letters I'm back
I think that's what it was you know
someone mentioned that the mistake he's
been making lately is that he's still in
2015 Underdog mindset I think it's
Patrick Bet David and that he's now he's
like the favorite so he does he needs to
use different tactics I think if he just
started doing short YouTube videos of
like I love you you're gonna do great in
life simple like basic he should eat a
taco bowl yeah you know eat the common
food speak to the common man but just
give them short bursts of positive
energy that's all he needs to do to
start rolling right now I'm not gonna be
happy till he's back on Twitter calling
Rosie O'Donnell fat I'm not like I'm not
gonna I mean until he's doing didn't he
say something about starting a a women's
WNBA team of men
no I heard someone said that I should
fact check that please do
and if it's true Donald please please do
please do maybe he didn't say that
somebody I someone told me that he said
that maybe maybe not I don't know um
it's all very topical I was just
watching this interview with Michael
malice and Patrick David on valiutan but
we talked about a little bit before the
show he uh and they were talking about
truth social the valuation of the
company has dipped apparently I haven't
been able to verify this but they were
both talking about it too it's like
worth half of what it was worth and that
they're like why hasn't he been on
Twitter well Patrick surmised that it's
probably because he's trying to get make
sure people keep coming to his website
to pay back his investors with Trump uh
the company that owns truth social uh
that SPAC that they did and then is that
dwac his dwac I'm not sure I'm not sure
but um that and they're like maybe if
truth Soldier because they were like
it's true social about to crumble like
is it falling apart are they about to
close it down and if it does is that
good for Trump and then they were
arguing whether it is or not some people
like it'll free them up he doesn't have
to please his past investors anymore he
can go do whatever he wants again I mean
it's it's down quite a bit
but uh that's only because when it
started it spiked and then I think dwack
reached like a hundred bucks a share
March 2020
around March of 2022 what is this
Trump's not as time without the audience
like Trump is like Trump isn't Trump's
you know Trump can say stuff on Truth
social but he's not like when he's
preaching to his own crowd it's not as
funny as when he's on Twitter with like
reply guys going at it and you know
saying things to get people worked up
because half the fun of trump on Twitter
was reading the replies and watching
people you know
make videos and stuff so I'm not I'm not
I'm not going to be happy until he's
fully restored Twitter do you consider
yourself political Johnny are you just
straight news I'm pretty straight I
think also like Trump's Twitter like you
were saying like it drove the news cycle
like I don't think truth social when he
posts on there it does that at all
nobody cares I think you need an account
to even read stuff it's crazy yeah you
got it you need to be at least publicly
able to be read if you wanted to be part
of the news cycle
the great thing about Trump was Cole
fluffy oh that's you're not getting that
with him posting your true social I'm
actually offended they won't tell us
what really happened well I wasn't we
had cash Patel here and he was like I
know what happened but I'm not telling
you and it's like dude how dare you we
must know the secrets of coffee he also
said that like only like it was only
like two people that actually knew and
I'm I'm dubious about whether anyone
knows at all somebody sausage fingered
the phone yeah they were yeah whoops I
sent it and then they were like whatever
another point that they were making
about the problems that true social may
be having it's tough to tell because
like you said there's a spike in the
beginning is that Elon Musk bought
Twitter and the whole point of true
social is we're gonna make a free speech
social network so he did it he set it up
they got investment they got it going
and then Elon bought Twitter and was
like now Twitter's a free speech social
network and everyone was like well
what's the point of Truth Now it also
really re like right away truth social
turned into the right wing so it wasn't
it wasn't just like the Free Speech
alternative it was so heavily part
Artisan that it became the antithesis to
Twitter so Twitter is where all the
left-leaning people were for a long time
so until musk look at Mastodon well
that's what happened yeah gone who talks
about Mastodon there's still some people
out there on Twitter they're really
committed leftists and their people are
committed to truth but doesn't matter
it's not in the conversation no no it's
not at all it's not at all partisan
social media is not the way social media
is supposed to be a neutral ground I
mean I think the best social media has
not been a neutral offering where people
can go at it if they want or they can
like communicate it's hard if someone's
like blocking a certain type of person
it's terrible and you know the thing
like there's a lot of people that that
when musk bought Twitter they were they
were upset that it wasn't a pure Free
Speech uh platform and I don't think
that there was ever gonna be I think
that that was a mistake to think that it
was ever going to be purely Free Speech
where like you know you you were never
going to have Twitter turned into
4chan's B board you know what I mean it
was never gonna be you know a Chan board
or whatever um but with musk there
aren't ideas that are repressed in the
same way that ideas were repressed when
you know the previous owners had Twitter
because the you know all the stuff with
that's coming out now about the about
you know whether it be the
administration or whether it be uh covid
stuff and and stuff with fauci or you
know where where covet came from it's
Etc that stuff would have been heavily
suppressed had the ownership still been
the previous owners I think that and I
don't think there's a lot of art I don't
think there's a lot of substance to
arguments against that perspective yeah
I agree did you were you thinking
something I mean I think like
as weird as it sounds I think like the
minute Elon took over
Twitter I was like holy crap all of the
DMs like in my spam DMS it was like so
many weird people that came through
which I guess is like a side effect of
having to like open up the entire space
but it was weird to see more interaction
that way more interaction and like
comments on things I think it really did
like open up what you know maybe people
consider Shadow Banning or you know
suppression of different accounts like I
think it really did change like
automatically I could tell and there was
like a week after he bought it I think
all a bunch of subscribers were lost and
gained by different accounts all at once
a lot of stuff what's that leftists were
losing followers like crazy and the
right was gaining I gained a huge chunk
I gained like well that means you're far
right you know seven percent of my
approvement or one percent or something
increased but it was a large increase
yeah that proves it guarantees lock them
up um
he said today he's going to be open
sourcing uh open source all code used to
recommend tweets on March 31st last week
from about five o'clock today that's
gonna be like there's gonna be a code in
there that says like if Donald Trump
equals yes then promote equals no yeah
I'm not even kidding I mean like
obviously he's got rid of that stuff but
we'll probably see some some stuff like
that that he didn't do that's fine yeah
he threads on and says that it's going
to be embarrassing for for him and for
Twitter for this stuff to be brought on
there because the code is so horribly
done he's just been complaining about it
for months but he said you know that's
the first step you it's the humility you
acknowledge how crappy it is and then
the community starts building it and
fixing it and contributing it's going to
be great this is the first step it's not
this doesn't mean he's open sourcing
everything in fact Minds reply the open
source organism will self-organize them
into something powerful this is the way
Bill talks yeah for sure to the social
media organisms open source organism
will self-organize into something
powerful I was like did you misspeak do
you mean Organization no that's how Bill
talks he thinks of social media as a
living organism in the universe and
stuff he talks about it like it's an
organized demon Maybe
sometimes the Borg Tick Tock is for sure
yeah creepy man it just ruined me
I'm a victim yes how often are you on
Tick Tock
um every morning every night it's the
only way I survive honestly really oh
yeah well what do you what are you
watching my brain you watch like and we
just talk about cutting their junk off
or something no no I'm not on that
algorithm I'm like on the like
influencer like you know girl who lives
in New York I'm on the cooking tick
tocks I'm on the Travel tick tocks the
chocolate dude the chocolate maker dude
dude there's this dude that makes
chocolate and like he'll make like he
made a velociraptor out of chocolate and
he made like like a crane arm thing out
of chocolate and it's like crazy crazy
stuff and people in the chat you know
who I'm talking about when I talk about
the chocolate kind I like the uh the
workout tick tocks because I'm I'm
trying to get my figure better so I have
to watch these women you know in yoga
pants all the time
it's completely ridiculous they do this
is this uh Omari guchon that I don't
know so when when you're on Tick Tock is
it like do you notice the algorithm feet
trying to feed you things to get you to
go down different paths oh yeah
absolutely and the problem is that when
you're in Social settings after you like
watch Tick Tock so much and you're so
addicted like you're always looking for
like that quick hit of dopamine and
you're not getting it in normal social
settings like you would on Tick Tock so
you're always like I'm so bored and like
I've cut myself off it's horrible and it
happens to a lot of people I'm pretty
sure like girls were getting like ticks
from Tick Tock that was a big story they
started twitching because they because
the algorithm would feed them videos of
women with Tourette's and then they
would watch these videos endlessly a
woman ticking and then they would start
developing ticks this is the crazy thing
when I saw a story like that I was like
maybe maybe women are more susceptible
to social engineering than men I mean I
think I shouldn't say maybe I think it's
factually true so the fact that women
can generate a fake Social Tourette's
says a lot about what social media is
doing to the fabric of society and I
don't think you can have the 19th
Amendment and social media at the same
time yeah I think we should keep the
knife
like oh no way no way social media is
way more jokes
AI is better than law You could argue
that like no amount of copyright law can
catch up with the amount of AI
advancement that thing's just completely
obliterating the 1500s law of can't
share my thing like it takes pictures
from all over the internet that are all
copywritten a bunch of them are and then
it just feeds you like totally violates
copyright law but there's no way to stop
it yeah I gotta say though about the
19th Amendment
now that I'm like sick and don't care
all that much
because I feel like crap I don't care
what these liberal Lefty women think
about about me or My Views anyway you
know so if like all the conservative
women are coming on this show and being
like yes we should repeal the 19th I'm
just gonna be like okay I guess thanks
for watching this clip from the timcast
IRL podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time